[SPEAKER_01]: [Automatic captions by Autotekst using OpenAI Whisper V3. May contain recognition errors.] It's always the same how far the community is ready to go to hide this
[SPEAKER_01]: accident, how far the organizer will go. What I believe is that this accident of Bram is highly controversial. And my point is, no matter
[SPEAKER_01]: what the responsibility could be, the liability issue could be, an organizer should always communicate about what happened in the
[SPEAKER_01]: competition.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's my main goal to let the people know that something went completely off the track. So to begin with, what exactly is Civil Resign? This
[SPEAKER_01]: movement is not targeting any individual. This movement is just willing that the institution acknowledge a fail, a massive
[SPEAKER_01]: institutional fail,
[SPEAKER_01]: And we need to enforce some new principles, new ways of thinking, new processes to stop these institutions failing. Julian Garcia, thank
[SPEAKER_00]: you so much for joining us at Paragliding Atlas. I just want to get things going right away because past two, three days, our community has seen a
[SPEAKER_00]: lot of talk on pretty much the same topic by quite a few notable names. And recently, civil resign has been, you can say, trending in a way where a
[SPEAKER_00]: lot of people are talking about it and supporting it. So to begin with, what exactly is civil resign? Thanks for having me first and in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not the first time and I appreciate a lot of your work. You know it. CVLO Resign is first CVL, is the institution that govern paragliding
[SPEAKER_01]: and hang gliding for the FII. So it's Sportive Discipline Commission of the FII, which is the Aeronautical International Federation. And this
[SPEAKER_01]: CVL is basically in charge of the development of a sport, organizing category one and event and events. giving the guidelines for
[SPEAKER_01]: activities, both in gliders and paragliders. And CIVL Resign is, as it's stated, is a movement to push for change into this institution and
[SPEAKER_01]: to push for a resignation of the Bureau. I am a French delegate for CIVL. I mean, I'm the representative at CIVL for France. And I thought at first
[SPEAKER_01]: it was after this World Championship. It's It was way too much. So I got in touch with my federation. We discussed some more and we came to the
[SPEAKER_01]: conclusion that the only call we had is to ask for a massive change, a massive shock into this institution. So I'll try to explain it better.
[SPEAKER_01]: Resignation. First, it's super important to understand that when you resign from some position, it is not meant to be forever. It does not mean
[SPEAKER_01]: you will disappear from the sport and you won't ever return. take any position in the activity. It's not that at all. And this movement is not
[SPEAKER_01]: targeting any individual specifically. Namely, this movement is just willing that the institution acknowledge a fail, which is basically
[SPEAKER_01]: the case. I hope we will discuss it more. But a big fail, a massive institutional fail, and we need to enforce some necessary new
[SPEAKER_00]: principle new ways of thinking new process to stop this institution failing so this is what it is about i understand so basically it's like we
[SPEAKER_00]: have done certain set of things in a certain way under a certain set of people and given them a trust and we are not really happy with the results
[SPEAKER_00]: that have been delivered and now maybe it's time for a change that's a fair point i believe yeah so we asked for new election for this you
[SPEAKER_01]: obviously need to resign because then there is no point waiting two more years in this kind of setup but most of all it's not new election and it's
[SPEAKER_01]: not about getting the people fired after a resignation you can apply for the new election as well even the same board the same people same
[SPEAKER_01]: everything but what really need to change is first put yourself on a new election because the things were massive And second, we need to make
[SPEAKER_01]: clear that we have to build some new process. And we discussed three main things in our letter, resignation letter, three big principles that we
[SPEAKER_01]: would love to see applied into this commission. Yeah, we'll get into that, Julian. For the perspective of our Let's say non-racing pilots,
[SPEAKER_00]: let's say pilots who go out and fly the sport for the love of flight, who are not a part of the circuit or are well-versed with this. And to
[SPEAKER_00]: highlight this a bit more, I would like to share my screen with you for a second. And we can start with there. Are you able to see my screen, Julia?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm seeing it, yeah. Right. So basically, this is an Instagram poll from a post of, I think, he's a Canadian pilot or something? UK
[SPEAKER_00]: pilot. UK, yeah. Fairly regular member in the competition circuit. And he had a post on 22nd, I believe. This is a day after Paul Tucker's. I think
[SPEAKER_00]: his was on 21st. And this post... has all the condolences and everything. But what made me really sad about reading this is that the
[SPEAKER_00]: undersigned in this post, Julian, are pilots, team leaders, and team doctors of the 2025 World Championship. So my question here is that how
[SPEAKER_00]: did it reach a stage where at the pinnacle of the competition in paragliding, the professional set of communication is coming in from
[SPEAKER_00]: the participants that are that is pilots leaders and the doctors with personal initiative and the official body has been silent what how did
[SPEAKER_00]: this happen try to tell you unfortunately this pilot had an accident went into an hospital he didn't die on the spot and We spent one week with a
[SPEAKER_01]: lot of uncertainty. And finally, unfortunately, Bram passed away. It was after the championship. We celebrated because there was
[SPEAKER_01]: uncertainty. We still were not sure. In a way, it's always the same. The culture is this way. So we go home and then Maxim, you know, suddenly
[SPEAKER_01]: realized, but come on, now this is getting ridiculous. We have the notification that he actually passed away. We really need to organize
[SPEAKER_01]: some kind of comment and some actual saying over this. So he went on the group, pilot group and asked if organizer would provide something and
[SPEAKER_01]: nothing came and Then it was even stated that FIE would never do this because it would be a first time. So we got, I will tell you, we got upset
[SPEAKER_01]: with this. And Maxime started to work on a communicate on his own. Theo from Greece changed a couple of editing, the words, et cetera, the
[SPEAKER_01]: letters. And then we just decided that we would post this anyway. So it's what Stan did, Maxime did, I did, and many others. And suddenly, the
[SPEAKER_01]: institution was kind of overwhelmed by what we did, and they decided to post stuff again. But I will tell you the background of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, what I believe is that this accident of Bram is highly controversial. And there is tons of reasons why an institution would
[SPEAKER_01]: love to not speak about it. And I don't get into much detail, but some people at least, I will stay very neutral, some people... believe that
[SPEAKER_01]: the goal field was poorly chosen, poorly set this day. Some concern was raised with safety committee on the mid-director as well. And then
[SPEAKER_01]: suddenly we still have an accident. Okay, it's hard because it will affect an organizer, it will affect the community. But on the other
[SPEAKER_01]: hand, it's also affecting a family. So my point is, no matter what the responsibility could be, the liability issue could be, an organizer
[SPEAKER_01]: should always communicate about safety. what happened in a competition. Then there is this communication about the dead. Of
[SPEAKER_01]: course, it's important. We had 10 accidents or I mean around 10 accidents during the competition. Broken ribs, broken back, broken
[SPEAKER_01]: legs, broken ankle. It's always the same. We had this discussion in your podcast about safety two months ago in Macedonia. It's always the same.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far the community is ready to go to hide this accident? How far the organizer will go into this? Okay. For the context of our listeners,
[SPEAKER_00]: that episode with Julian is a masterpiece of a one which will be coming soon. It is unreleased yet. But so to clarify, as humans, pilots can make
[SPEAKER_00]: mistakes, organizers can make mistakes. It's a part of the human nature. There's no finger pointing or personal blaming here. But let's
[SPEAKER_00]: say when it comes to showing compassion in times of need, dire, consistent needs, regardless of your history of slipping ups, I think
[SPEAKER_00]: it would be on the basis of humanity that you would put a condolence post out there. And if pilots have to take their own initiative in a
[SPEAKER_00]: rebellious manner, let's say what Maxine did, Which was, again, out of humanity, not to forget. Are we losing some sort of the compassion
[SPEAKER_00]: connection between the ones who are calling the shots and the ones who are actually playing the field? Because that is what I see. And if that is
[SPEAKER_00]: the case, then, of course, it's a very fair call for civil rights. to resign because let's say whatever has happened was history, but
[SPEAKER_00]: actively taking steps to suppress the voice for the cause of someone who's not there is, it just seems a bit unhuman to me, if I'm honest,
[SPEAKER_00]: Julian. I don't think we lost this humanity and this And this empathy, even inside your institution to discharge CVL constantly on this very
[SPEAKER_01]: topic and on the topic of empathy, there was support for the family. There was support for the pilot. They got in touch. They went to the
[SPEAKER_01]: hospital. They did everything that could have been done in case of an accident. So, in fact, some member of this community said, they really
[SPEAKER_01]: feel and they really cared about getting the right thing done. The organization in Brazil did everything it could. The local one, the
[SPEAKER_01]: hospital was perfect. Everything was perfect. great from the words of the companion of brahm and the friends of ram so at this level i'm very
[SPEAKER_01]: confident that the individual are great humans great people and they do whatever that they can the trouble is not there the trouble is
[SPEAKER_01]: institutional then suddenly there is a collective responsibility and no one feel entitled to take it yeah there is multiple bodies organizers
[SPEAKER_01]: cvl and fii and the responsibility the framework here is not clear who does what the principle they are just the workflow is not defined
[SPEAKER_01]: anywhere in case of a situation like this which is the dramatic by the way but this all comes first to the actual work of a commission
[SPEAKER_01]: international commission because mainly it's what we we say with this movement this institution is mainly focused into organizing events
[SPEAKER_01]: and too little focuses into providing the sport a real structure and a real path to grow on a more professional level meaning We see several
[SPEAKER_01]: vice president or whoever involved directly in the bureau getting into the event and acting as a steward or as a jury, getting his hand into such
[SPEAKER_01]: an event. In which kind of federation, institution would you see something like that? A president or a vice president, a bureau board
[SPEAKER_01]: member coming and getting the things done by himself into an organizational point of view. This is crazy. This is not the point at
[SPEAKER_01]: all, not the role at all of... those kind of people we need them a lot we need them a lot to structure the sport to get the medical requirement to
[SPEAKER_01]: get the organizational format to A lot of things need to be done and they are consistently put aside just because they are busy organizing
[SPEAKER_01]: events, which is nice, but just not enough. Got it. So professionalism is the need of the hour because day after day, lives are being put at stake
[SPEAKER_00]: and in the hope that this won't happen to me. But that is, again, subjective. And when that happens to you, Nobody can project that, but
[SPEAKER_00]: the point is that there needs to be a certain set of framework which at least ensures long-term safety standards which are good enough, if I
[SPEAKER_00]: decode this correctly. Yes, these, but also you can... Think about mid-director curriculum and certification, safety director
[SPEAKER_01]: certification, life tracker formation and education. It's a full kind of tools that are actually lacking, but not because of the people are
[SPEAKER_01]: bad, just because the institution don't work the way it should be and don't work on the right topic, in my opinion. Fair enough. So let's say
[SPEAKER_00]: for listeners tuning in right now, If we have to clarify, what are the main demands that are being put on the table for the negotiation when
[SPEAKER_00]: asking for resignation? For the moment, we really need to rebuild this commission. What we see, and I will tell exactly why we are here, we see
[SPEAKER_01]: super bad statistics into Cat1 event since ages. And last world championship in France, it was probably more than 20 accidents. no
[SPEAKER_01]: fatalities, but it was mostly luck, 20 accidents, and this time, it's again around 10 with one fatality. In the last hang gliding edition, one
[SPEAKER_01]: guy in coma, one guy dead, and 20 accidents again. So, come on, let's first just, nothing appointed, nothing badly intended, but just let's
[SPEAKER_01]: recognize this problem first. So, how do you recognize such a problem at a super high level of institution? you just resign and then we rebuild
[SPEAKER_01]: it's not a pure resignation it's not to forget your name or forget your face forget your commitment it's not the way but you resign and then we
[SPEAKER_01]: put some new framework into the institution which are the three key principle we would like to enforce Before talking about safety, about
[SPEAKER_01]: format, about whatever we need to enforce and whatever we need to do on the safety matters, we need this commission to work again and to be able
[SPEAKER_01]: to properly produce some effect on the field. Makes sense. Would you briefly want to describe those three points that you mentioned in your
[SPEAKER_00]: letter? Because I do have screenshots of it, but I think we can just... Talk through it. It'll be better for the listeners. Yeah. So the first
[SPEAKER_01]: one, which is in my opinion, super important is that the political should absolutely take care of the developing the sport, the
[SPEAKER_01]: structuring the sport. So it's what we just discussed before. It's minimum requirement for safety guidelines. it's again a mid-director
[SPEAKER_01]: safety director curriculum certification which are non- existent at the moment can you imagine yourself being mid-director of a 120 pilot in
[SPEAKER_01]: a world championship without actually having attended to no kind of course no kind of education just by experience just because you are
[SPEAKER_01]: designed by an organization you go there and you do the job yeah that's weird sounds weird It shouldn't be this way. We should have some
[SPEAKER_01]: educational courses and some common reasoning about how we do a task, how we set a task, how we do stop a task, how many level three you stop a
[SPEAKER_01]: task. Plenty of stuff that are super important to enforce and to structure better the sport and then also different format sport class
[SPEAKER_01]: is still yet to come it's super important to have category for mass competing right now more and more pilots want and demand to compete but
[SPEAKER_01]: for sure ccc class is not for everybody so we should structure this more so that would be the first point to structure the sport Second point
[SPEAKER_01]: would more be about separating politics than technical. Actually, on the CEVL level, at this commission, international commission, you can
[SPEAKER_01]: be either politician and at the same time, perfectly technician. So you are elected as president, vice president, and you can go to be jury or
[SPEAKER_01]: steward. Into some event, you can work with live tracker owning a live tracking company, no trouble. You can do whatever you want. In fact,
[SPEAKER_01]: basically, you can accumulate any source of power, any source of some are involved in both association paragliding World Cup runs event
[SPEAKER_01]: themselves as an organizer in some part of the world and still inside the board of the association. There is nothing against that so far. It's
[SPEAKER_01]: perfectly, there is no, no, it's not against the law. It's not, there is no, nothing bad. It's just that for the functioning of the association,
[SPEAKER_01]: it suddenly doesn't work. It doesn't work. So the proposal is you get elected to the board. Suddenly you are politician. So you work to
[SPEAKER_01]: develop the sport and on the, on the structure side, you don't go into events. You don't go into organizing stuff yourself. And on the
[SPEAKER_01]: opposite, you want to organize stuff yourself. Well done. You are into working group. You are welcomed. You are into the organizer, the
[SPEAKER_01]: organizational stuff of the stewards or jury on the main event. It's perfectly fine. But you cannot be both. This show really sees because
[SPEAKER_01]: then there is conflict of interest everywhere. And this is what we witness now. So that would be a fair second point, I guess. I think I
[SPEAKER_00]: really like this assessment of yours because I've been calling a few people to get some more information about this. And I also was
[SPEAKER_00]: researching this episode. And one thing that I came across while discussing was that a number of times we see that there are a few
[SPEAKER_00]: gatekeepers of the society, most of which are like, let's say, in regular day, in normal life, it's big tech because they have all the
[SPEAKER_00]: resources and everything. And in our niche sport, it's usually the big manufacturers which drive the direction in which the sport grows and in
[SPEAKER_00]: which the R&D kind of where the money goes, basically where the market flows. So I was coming across a point that a lot of times it's the same guy
[SPEAKER_00]: who is designing for a brand or working in a brand And the same guy who is also a part of the PMA, which is responsible for making certain
[SPEAKER_00]: decisions to keep the manufacturers in check. And then also the same person is in working group six, which is also responsible for deciding
[SPEAKER_00]: how the future generations will be able to enjoy the sport. So the point is a very valid one. I think one head, multiple roles sounds really good
[SPEAKER_00]: when it comes to efficiency and saving money or cutting the operational costs. but it comes at a hidden cost, which we are failing to identify as
[SPEAKER_00]: industry. And I think you guys have put it very well in that point number two there. I completely agree with that. Yeah, and there is another much
[SPEAKER_01]: more simpler issue with the multiplying cap. In fact, you cannot be, there is only 24 hours a day. You cannot take charge of concretely and
[SPEAKER_01]: correctly of all those aspects multiplying aspects it's impossible so what you will do you will prioritize some and some you will let down and
[SPEAKER_01]: it's perfectly understandable but then some points don't work and it's actually what we experience there are things that are clearly too slow
[SPEAKER_01]: and clearly not evolving enough so that would be it Indeed. So about the point three, I would like to enforce and we would like with federation to
[SPEAKER_01]: enforce more democratic election into the venue, the bids. So where do the pilot go? What's next competition? So world championship,
[SPEAKER_01]: European championship, Asian championship. Right now, the system is that we the delegate are voting this. So it's the by statute of the FII.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the main election. representative of the plenary and of every NAC every NAC has one so every nation has one and it's up to those
[SPEAKER_01]: representatives to go and vote for the venue but it should really be more like pilot stuff to to choose the next place because the organization
[SPEAKER_01]: they are mostly known by the pilot and sometimes things get a bit political when you are invited somewhere in the plenary and You spent a
[SPEAKER_01]: week there or three or four days there, and the host is putting a bid. And so who will vote against his man suddenly? He's our host. He hosted us
[SPEAKER_01]: during three, four days. And suddenly it's a bit hard to vote against something he would forward. And anyway, there are many situations
[SPEAKER_01]: where the delegates are actually a bit far from their pilots because it's, again, National Aero Club. Some of the delegates are not
[SPEAKER_01]: themselves pilots. It's not about a real sportive role. It's mostly a political and administrative role. So I really think we should find a
[SPEAKER_01]: solution to make online voting on small pool, maybe three pilot per nation, two pilot per nation. And at least we would have a more fine
[SPEAKER_01]: notion of what the pilots are actually wanting. On this occasion, a world championship should have been organized in Andradas, in Brazil.
[SPEAKER_01]: And for whatever reason, it was not possible. And the Bureau decided to go for Castelo instead, or for Brazil still. But it shouldn't really be
[SPEAKER_01]: possible to let such a decision to a single or a couple of single men into the institution. It's acknowledged that they did it for good. They did
[SPEAKER_01]: it to not lose another world championship, which is perfectly nice. But still, We really need to discuss it on a more pilot level and more
[SPEAKER_01]: democratic way. I believe it's too much of importance. I think it's important to be in a position to have an honest and unhindered
[SPEAKER_00]: conversation, especially in today's time when people find it harder and harder to speak what they feel. But is this something what Marcella
[SPEAKER_00]: got reprimanded for in the posts? Marseille has sent a letter to the CIVL after they announced that they would switch the World Championship.
[SPEAKER_01]: After they announced they would pass it from Andradas to Castelo. And we, as French, we signed this letter because we thought it was also a bad
[SPEAKER_01]: idea to go there at this moment of the year. But also because it was a little time to organize everything. such an event and the new organizer
[SPEAKER_01]: could have difficulty doing so and so we signed this letter and unfortunately the answer of the institution was pretty harsh and
[SPEAKER_01]: pretty heavy they actually with the knack with brazilian knack they actually threatened her to lose her sportive license and to not be able
[SPEAKER_01]: to compete into the world championship this reaction made his boyfriend Marcella's boyfriend, Rafa Barros, which is the strongest
[SPEAKER_01]: pilot in Brazil, declined his selection for the World Championship. I don't know if you imagine the madness it is, in fact. For me, this fact
[SPEAKER_01]: only is already enough to underline a massive problem in our institution. Suppressing voice is never a good sign. And I think it's
[SPEAKER_00]: very brave of her boyfriend to come up and stand next to her. And I think we are more or less talking about the same underlying fact that a more
[SPEAKER_00]: athlete-oriented approach would, first of all, prevent such scenarios in the first case. And secondly, if they do arise, they should
[SPEAKER_00]: be handled in a much more professional manner. I think that is what your point number three is trying to address in here. Yeah, I really wish for
[SPEAKER_01]: my institution to act as much more responsible and much more transparent as well. And so far, it's not about the people inside, it's
[SPEAKER_01]: just the framework. were that was provided is almost nothing and so it's a kind of freedom that gets just too much and yeah and the result is poor so
[SPEAKER_00]: now basically we have discussed what this movement is all about and more importantly what was the kind of cause that got it rolling and why a need
[SPEAKER_00]: for this moment was felt in the first place but now let's say julian for those listeners who are wondering how to do their own bit because this
[SPEAKER_00]: seems to be a noble cause which is eventually for the greater good. So how does the community get involved and how can people listening to this be a
[SPEAKER_00]: part of the tribe? I didn't feel hope that the bureau will ask the call and do resign so we can built a future with them inside the new team, inside
[SPEAKER_01]: the new institution. And so my main goal and the main goal at French Federation is to keep the pressure on social media and to tell them
[SPEAKER_01]: what's happened is wrong and what happened shouldn't have been this way and we need a change. So The first thing is visibility. We need to make
[SPEAKER_01]: this movement visible much more. It's a small movement for the moment and we need much more. I started it on Instagram because I'm only there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably a ton of things to do on Facebook and elsewhere. So I do need relay. I do need more visibility and we need much more pressure into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's only the first part because this is mediatical. So the point is for them, the main thing is they go to event. For sure, it would be
[SPEAKER_01]: unsuitable to go to an event where people into the same event ask their resignation. It's not fun suddenly. So it's my main goal to let the
[SPEAKER_01]: people know and to convince more people that something went completely off the track. And second, it's true that they can just stick and wait
[SPEAKER_01]: until February or March. to the next plenary and this is perfectly normal by status it's always work and it's not elective so it's just a
[SPEAKER_01]: normal plenary the next one will be two years and then at the plenary for sure france will propose to vote against the president report and to
[SPEAKER_01]: vote against and to vote in favor of a proposal of resignation of the bureau if we are allowed to and then things will get more political so how
[SPEAKER_01]: can you help first visibility i just said and second you find your delegate a national delegate and you explain and you show him this video
[SPEAKER_01]: and you explain the letter and you explain all that went wrong in the past and how it's important to rebuild this commission not with new people
[SPEAKER_01]: necessarily but with new principle and new ways of doing things that's the key point if Most of the time, a delegate will say, oh, resignation.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's too hot. Oh, no, we don't want that. We will cut the head of some people. I don't want that. It's nothing like this. Resignation doesn't
[SPEAKER_01]: mean, again, you quit forever. It's resignation. It's acknowledging and being responsible when things go wrong. wisely said Julian those
[SPEAKER_00]: are like very powerful words there and I just I really hope from bottom of my heart this becomes a reality because it seems like finally I wouldn't
[SPEAKER_00]: call this a watershed moment by far but let's say back in 2011 when we lost out on open class. It was made possible because more or less people have
[SPEAKER_00]: had enough by then of the constant carnage that was going on and decided to make a change in the masses. So regardless of whatever you may feel
[SPEAKER_00]: that I'm too small of a pilot, I just fly an E and A or a B wing, I've just 50 hours, like, well, this is a communication talk for like competition
[SPEAKER_00]: pilots who fly triple c's it's not that guys let me be honest it's the initiative when somebody takes this is always for the greater good and
[SPEAKER_00]: for not censoring but in fact encouraging free speech which of course here translates into more professionalism more in-depth r d and safety
[SPEAKER_00]: norms details of which we discussed over here and the three main points of julia So there is much more to this moment rather than just building
[SPEAKER_00]: momentum to remove someone out of anger. This is not a rage bait, as Julian repeatedly mentions in his posts and even during the talk. This
[SPEAKER_00]: is for the possibility to have a safer tomorrow, if you allow me to put it like that, Julian. Thanks a lot. It's really summed up. And from all the
[SPEAKER_01]: talk I got today, I think you are the one who understood it the most. So thanks for... reading carefully all the communication. Thanks for not
[SPEAKER_01]: just sticking to save or resign and just not read what it's all about. And yeah, I think, again, your work is amazing. So thank you very much for
[SPEAKER_01]: having me. No, you're welcome, Julian. Thanks for the appreciation. And I think it's mutual feelings here. So going forward, all of us will
[SPEAKER_00]: stay tuned and we'll continue doing our own bit to make this a more fun and a more safe place to be. Thanks, Anindya.